cómo
[Música]
conectamos a esta hora con nuestro
segundo invitado de directo américa para
seguir analizando cuál es el impacto de
la muerte de la reina isabel segunda y
que monarquía es la que recibe el rey
carlos tercero conectamos entonces a
esta hora con erick fajardo él es
profesor e investigador universitario y
tiene una maestría en comunicación
política y es además especialista en
análisis de conflicto
eric bienvenido nos saludamos a usted
que está en virginia eeuu y quiero
preguntarle precisamente a propósito de
su tema de especialización y es
preguntarle sobre el conflicto
norirlandés con reino unido y con los
ingleses cuál fue el papel de la reina y
recordemos que este conflicto armado lo
desató precisamente que tan adeptos se
consideraban o no los norirlandeses a la
corona británica o qué tan irlandeses se
sentían
bien gracias creo que es fundamental
analizar el papel de isabel segunda en
la historia no solamente de inglaterra
sino de esto que ha venido a llamarse el
reino unido porque ella se ha convertido
desde mi punto de vista en el
catalizador
cultural político histórico de la
transición de lo que solía ser el
imperio británico o gran bretaña a lo
que hoy día se conoce como el reino
unido es decir de la concepción del
imperio hada a la concepción actual de
la mancomunidad de las islas las cinco
islas es una mancomunidad junto con
otros 52 países que se declaran súbditos
de la influencia cultural de lo que
alguna vez un imperio en esta transición
en las corrientes post coloniales y neo
independentistas entre los 60 así y la
actualidad sin duda ha sido una pulseta
permanente la relación de lo que solía
ser la cabeza o la capital de la gran
bretaña con algunos otros países con los
que comparte fuerte identidad cultural
como irlanda gales escocia pero también
con los que hay
relaciones de subordinación que
subvirtieron y que generaron en esos
países movimientos independentistas
movimientos de liberación que
contendieron en términos militares con
seguramente en la égida o con el régimen
de la gran bretaña hoy día sin embargo
podemos decir sin temor a equivocarnos
que este papel de 69 años de la corona
de isabel segunda fue algo que galvanizó
más allá de la historia política y más
allá de los desencuentros ideológicos la
existencia y la coexistencia entre los
miembros de la mancomunidad son 52
naciones alrededor del mundo que cuando
esto empezó cuando se creó la
mancomunidad cuando el padre de la reina
isabel segunda creó la mancomunidad allá
por 1950 ésta tenía apenas 8 gran
bretaña estaba sufriendo el impacto de
la disgregación natural del post
colonialismo estaba perdiendo territorio
y estaba además cediendo muchas de las
que habían sido colonias en términos
políticos administrativos del imperio
recuperarlas reintegrarlas si yo diría
rico para la mancomunidad para este otro
margen de este espectro ideológico
cultural de pertenencia fue tarea de
isabel yo creo que no solamente con
irlanda sino con todos los otros
miembros de la gran mancomunidad de la
unión en el reino unido- el papel de
ella fue fundamental y precisamente fue
fundamental su rol para pasar del
imperio a la mancomunidad que fue esta
figura que ella tanto potenció para no
perder del todo los vínculos estrechos
que tenía con las naciones que fueron
colonia británica yo quiero volver un
poco a irlanda del norte y es se conoce
la discreción de la reina en temas
políticos ella jamás se pronunció
públicamente al respecto como fue su
papel durante la guerra con irlanda del
norte
el papel de isabel ha sido prolijo quizá
de ahí viene esta transición tan estable
entre la autoridad política que solía
tener la monarquía la autoridad moral
que tiene hoy la corrección política de
la reina el sentido de oportunidad
además el ser capaz de comunicarse
epistolarmente es decir por discursos
muy calculados muy medidos muy mesurados
ha evitado que lo que fue una atención
de años de décadas esta polaridad es
religioso política no es todo el eje de
dublín belfast y la relación tensa con
el reino unido- tuviese desde mi punto
de vista una solución pacífica fue una
influencia muy positiva entiendo yo no
no hubo un intento de aplastamiento ni
en la relación con irlanda ni tampoco en
la relación con ningún otro de los
países que anteriormente pudieron haber
sido súbditos o estar subrogados a la
corona británica tal y como le digo una
importante comprensión en isabel segunda
de lo que significaba mantener la
influencia ideológica cultural de la
corona una vez que la influencia
político administrativa se había perdido
fue una transición que no han logrado
muchos reinos hacerlo si usted compara
la monarquía solamente en europa de
españa o de algunos otros reinos como
bélgica han habido esfuerzos incluso en
la misma francia por preservar la
influencia cultural que bajo la égira
napoleónica o bajo la égida de carlos
quinto pudiera haber existido sobre las
ex colonias ninguna ha sido tan exitosa
y quizá la clave de eso por eso no me
limito toda la relación con irlanda ha
sido que la reina comprendió la
importancia de su rol moral y de su
papel como embajadora de aunar la
cultura británica alrededor del mundo de
es más uno de los datos y yo destacó
siempre es que su papel ha sido tan
trascendente para mí como el de un
polaco llamado karol wojtyla es decir
sólo el papa juan pablo segundo entendió
la importancia de su rol a la cabeza de
la iglesia en el caso de isabel a la
cabeza de la corona británica para hacer
sobrevivir la monarquía una
supervivencia que hoy día ya no veo tan
asegurada con su sucesor vamos a ver qué
sucede todavía la coronación va a llevar
algún tiempo para hacer efectiva y antes
de hacer ese repaso por las
consecuencias y que le puede esperar al
nuevo monarca quiero detenernos en otra
de las guerras que le tocó a la reina
isabel durante su mandato y fue la
guerra de las malvinas donde además tuvo
una gran diferencia con margaret
thatcher como fue este rol moral del que
usted nos habla de la reina respecto a
la guerra de las malvinas que es mucho
más cercana a nosotros
bien hay que entender que en el mismo
reino unido- en la misma gran bretaña ha
existido desde el principio de la
democratización parlamentaria una fuerte
tendencia desde el laborismo a abolir el
trono británico- es decir abolir el
sistema monárquico hay en la ciudadanía
hay en los británicos en un fuerte
arraigo una raigambre profunda de lo que
significa esta autoridad moral de esta
institución más de corte cultural
antropológico que político pero también
han habido importantes movimientos
durante antes y después de la revolución
industrial buscando la abolición del
sistema monárquico en los discursos post
coloniales de los setentas fueron un
fuerte implican te de la idea de que la
monarquía debía terminar como sobrevivir
a ese proceso como haberlo hecho eso es
virtud de isabel segunda desde mi
perspectiva estoy convencido de que hay
una relación
discursiva desde un punto de vista que
los comunicadores políticos sabemos
percibir muy bien el lenguaje en
realidad la comunicación tiene 11
niveles
uno de ellos uno es el verbal todos los
demás son raramente utilizados por los
políticos y saben utilizó muy bien la
próxima el lenguaje estético la
simbólica es decir todos los otros
niveles del lenguaje que no implicaban
pronunciarse que es quizá el único nivel
del lenguaje que tiene un efecto
político irreversible los utilizó y en
la campaña bueno fue una campaña más
dirigida desde lo político desde la
primera ministra margaret thatcher pero
en la relación con las malvinas se
abstuvo de pronunciarse o de tener un
pronunciamiento político de tener un
pronunciamiento que tuviera implicancias
geopolíticas lo cual salvo en ese
momento en un duro conflicto que se ha
entendido desde latinoamérica como
ocupación como un golpe colonialista de
asociar la figura de la monarquía
británica con la acción política del
parlamentarismo y de la de la gran
bretaña como unidad político
administrativa sí precisamente de estos
múltiples lenguajes de los que usted
hablaba está una historia bastante
relevante y bastante recordada que es
cuando el reino unido se aproximaba
y el presi de la reina vistió de azul y
amarillo que son los colores de la
bandera de la unión europea y del bloque
de los 27 uno de los tantos lenguajes y
la reina fue sin duda una experta para
transmitir mensajes a través de su
vestimenta y en ese sentido su por
reinventar su comunicación sin embargo
tenemos entonces un nuevo rey con nuevos
retos una época totalmente distinta a
usted mencionaba precisamente los
movimientos anticolonialistas de los 70
una narrativa que ha acogido muchísima
más fuerza ahora y que el colonialismo
ha quedado por lo menos desde la palabra
y desde el deseo quiere dejarse atrás en
ese sentido el rey carlos tercero tiene
muchos más retos en esta sociedad
usted brevemente nos adelantaba que duda
de cómo lo va a hacer él cuáles son
entonces esos retos y qué tan preparado
está carlos tercero que además lleva 73
años de su vida preparándose para subir
al trono
yo no sé si se ha preparado 73 años
pienso que hay una definición en el
carácter de carlos muy próxima al de a
la de su tío eduardo octavo no es el rey
que aplicó y que permitió la ascensión
de isabel segunda yo veo muy dentro de
la lógica de ese ese pariente que él
tiene de quería una vida personal o de
haber ambicionado durante muchos de esos
73 años más el tener una realización
como individuo que el asumir un rol de
símbolo porque eso es en realidad la
corona británica es un símbolo y el rey
o la reina y eso es lo que por 69 años
hizo isabel al enorme costo que
seguramente eso tuve lo familiar y lo
personal eso fue lo que ella construyó
cuánto puedes sobrevivir esta imagen de
lo que la realeza es además una imagen
impoluta una imagen muy prístina que ha
construido y saber con carlos tengo
severas dudas los escándalos de
corrupción han salpicado permanentemente
el comportamiento del príncipe charles
como individuo las denuncias de the sun
se multiplicaron a pesar apenas menos
meses atrás
a la manera como su fundación recibió
dinero de otros gobiernos recibió
gobierno de dinero de bin laden de la
familia bin laden es decir estamos ante
una situación de no estoy seguro si va a
poder preservar la imagen de autoridad
moral que se necesita en una regencia
que hoy día está yo desde mi punto de
vista lo veo más aún bajo fuego que los
mismos 70 el globalismo y el laborismo
van a ser un factor de asedio permanente
y vigilante del comportamiento político
de este régimen viene en una crisis
política en este momento gran bretaña en
la cual no solamente el rol de liz tras
la nueva un primer ministro sino y sobre
todo el rol social la manera cómo va a
simbolizar el rey estos valores de la
gran bretaña van a ser fuertemente
vigilados estamos entonces si una
situación yo diría si quiero quiero
interrumpirlo porque no quiero
despedirlo sin antes preguntarle y
pedirle que acerque este tema un poco
más a nuestra audiencia y digo en
américa latina donde no tenemos
monarquías ni reinados
implica esto y qué efectos tiene en la
vida cotidiana de los británicos este
rol social y este impacto moral del rey
o es definitivo y yo lo asociaría ya que
vamos a hablar con latinoamérica con el
impacto que algunos símbolos telúricos
algunos símbolos en la tradición
indígena clase media en latinoamérica
tienen hereden en el perú en la zona
andina el tema de la pachamama la madre
tierra la relación con la madre tierra
eso es lo que isabel construyó durante
su periplo de 69 años a bordo del
britania me gusta decir que su palacio
no fué buckingham su palacio fue el
britannia ella construyó una relación
así de cercanas y de telurica como
seguramente las culturas americanas
tienen con la idea de la madre tierra es
una asociación inmediata que pesa en el
imaginario británico que es una
situación de orgullo y de reconocimiento
es un elemento de identidad